hello my name is Roy and right on my
transporter the dice that die a toy toy
that's my hilarious Jason Statham
impression or Statham for you [ __ ]
[ __ ] we got a new trailer app or a
really enter this is I think the most
anticipated sequel in the franchise for
sure for obvious reasons Furious 7 the
sequel to fast six which was the sequel
to Fast Five which was the sequel to
Fast and Furious which was a sequel The
Fast and Furious Tokyo Drift
which was then that was this equal to 2
fast 2 furious which was a sequel to The
Fast and the Furious we had seven of
these movies yeah I mean it sucks that
Paul Walker passed away especially
before the release of this movie because
people I was already really looking
forward to this because James Wan is the
director I loved his films and I thought
it was so cool that he's taking on a
totally different type of genre I love
it when a director does that and goes
all out it does suck that he's not
around for it but it's Paul Walker's the
one franchise that we always loved him
in and he's even when he's not doing a
great job in the movies he's still like
something's really charming about this
guy then diesel man it's about family
that's my my impression of him in this
movie it's about family and Jason
Statham they've established he is the
villain excited because I love Jason
Statham he's the same in every [ __ ]
movie these days but he is so cool I
loved him in the early days before I
became an American star you know I liked
him in lock stock I liked them in snatch
I even liked him in the one with Jet Li
the classic here we go isla I love bass
6 in Fast Five is so exciting alright
let's get to work
they run when you're freaking out no yes
you are somebody just walk me through
what we supposed to be doing just
[ __ ]
that's [ __ ] awesome posts
god damn dear let me get you out of here
Oh fine
I love it blasting fast your bathroom
looks like the sins of London have
followed us home remember Owen Shaw this
is big pepper being hunted no witness
ago
that is going for work this is a room
please
like it or not you and your friends are
a part of it now don't have friends I
got family happy setting that film looks
like this isn't it for sure
holy [ __ ] dude I want to get off this
couch what I loved about Fast Five and
then fast six was they finally realized
just how ridiculous this franchise needs
to commit to this just looks like they
took it to the next level and the
direction the way it's captured I could
see the James Wan touch and I could see
the different type of direction that
it's that it kind of has but it looks
like great [ __ ] action sequences it
looks like [ __ ] adrenalin fuel I love
that there's finally a scene where they
pretend to be these rich ass classy
[ __ ] finally you need one of
those scenes in these kinds of movies so
thank you it just looks like what the
definition of fun is like when fast six
came out those are my favorite movies of
the year because it was just pure
entertainment it looks like that but
even hiding with a cool simple type of
vengeance tale like that's awesome and
Jason Statham is doing it Jason Statham
thing is fighting being badass and stuff
but you know it's cool Vin Diesel
it's about family it's about family
that's really the message of these films
family it's not even a [ __ ] joke
that's the actual message of these car
heist films it's about family anyway
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects where
we keep it real to get it it's so stupid
right facebook.com slash the real
rejects shoutouts Gio Figueroa may I
please have my shout out Thank You Ryan
Gio Figueroa dude I'm about to let the
world in on a secret I live close to
Figueroa Street now Figueroa streets a
very long street but if you get up every
home in Figueroa you won't find me
because I live close to Figueroa Gio
Figueroa that is the son of the man who
invented Figueroa Street Figueroa is
full of a lot of crimes a lot of lot of
hookers and drugs the hookers run the
city you don't go there cops don't tress
pass onto Figueroa that's the that's the
plot of old town in Sin City
I've been Simon so how come all the
girls in the channel seem really cool
with every with whatever you say and
girls in Texas act like they have stick
up their butts maybe it's just time to
move to California I'm assuming it wants
a shout-out because this is on the real
rejection of page
Evans Simon look here is why the girls
will respond however will be accepting
whatever I say it has nothing to do with
the fact that I'm really good-looking
it's all about I don't know an answer I
I don't I thought I could make something
up but I'm just very lucky I don't know
because I camera if he gets funny I
don't quite know as if I make those
comments off-camera they're just like oh
that's right I don't know why girls in
Texas have sticks up their butts but
maybe if that's the problem because you
know a lot of girls don't like having
stuff up their butts some do anal rectum
pleasure I think is what the word is mr.
Joe Nichols one hey Ryan I watch your
channel a lot I think it is a lot of fun
can I get a shout out mr. Joe Nichols
one you look like a emo version of mm
I'm looking at your photo right now you
kind of look like Paul Walker meets mm
but a really depressed version like you
look really sad in your thumbnail let me
see if I could save a picture of your
thumbnail so I can show the world now
you're either trying to be sexy
or you're really depressed anyway mr.
Joe Nichols one that's your shoutout